what do you think Rupert Murdoch and Fox
News need to do to regain some trust oh
oh I don't think it's just Fox I I mean
I'll put them in there but all of media
all of Television media and everyone has
to own a little bit of the lack of trust
the lack of accountability it's okay to
get something wrong in the news but you
got to come back and own it and whether
it's fox or CNN or MSNBC or you know
whatever everyone just has to
intentionally lying to viewers though
that that to me seemed across the line
you're all in the same basket I could go
to CNN when they talk when they they're
going to ignore the the hunter Biden
laptop story we could talk about the
virus coming truly coming out of the lab
in Wuhan if you're not owning that you
misrepresented the story whether it was
intentional or not he did a really nice
job there the line you're all in the
same bucket that's what he's saying to
Chuck Todd you all lie about everything
and then that Chuck Todd with a straight
face has the gall to be like well
intentionally lying intentionally lying
to viewers though that that to me seemed
to cross the line